- You've done a lot of voiceover work.
- I've done a few films and
we've had a good time with that.
- Well, I also hear that
you like aloha shirts,
do you do your voice,
because one thing I love
about voiceovers, I don't
have to do all this.
You can go in looking crazy bad.
- And I have.
- Yeah.
- I have.
The beauty of doing a
voiceover, you walk in there,
it's night and day from
doing a regular film.
You know that already.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You go in there, you don't
have to memorize anything.
If you show up in your
pajamas, they judge you,
but they don't care.
(crowd laughing)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Gabriel] The check still clears,
you know what I'm saying?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it's a lot of fun.
- But I heard you do love,
- Oh oh oh oh, yeah I'm not wearing
an aloha shirt right now, I have
people now that dress me.
- That dress you?
- Yeah.
I do too!
- Oh 'cause if it was up to me, man,
I'd be wearing one of these pillows.
(crowd laughing)
- I survive in jeans and t-shirts,
so I don't dress up, this is all Candice,
I have a person, but I
love your aloha shirts.
- I know.
- I love them.
I thought that was really cool.
Everyone calls you fluffy though, why?
(Gabriel groaning)
Your tour is called that.
- I know, right?
I've had that nickname forever.
It was something that my mom gave me.
It's one of those things
where she didn't like,
"Mijo, you're not fat.
"You're fluffy."
(crowd clapping)
- I got "you're just big-boned."
That's what I got, which
sounds just as gross as fat.